earlier in the programme we were
discussing the countries committed to
reducing new coal power construction as
well as norway's election which was
largely run on climate change issues so
the question is is there a role for
fossil fuels beyond 2050 well i'm joined
now by fatima ibrahim co-founder of the
green new deal uk and bob ward from the
grantham research institute on climate
change and the environment good to see
both of you fatima coming to you first
do you think there will still be demand
for fossil fuels in 30 years
i mean absolutely not if we're even
remotely interested in avoiding climate
disaster and ensuring a future that is
not just livable but promises
opportunity to thrive then there needs
to be no role for oil and gas and fossil
fuels beyond 2050 and waiting until 2050
is even a gamble the oil and gas
industry are betting on and wanting us
to bet our future on unproven
technologies of carbon capture and
storage so that they can stay in
business but the science is clear we
need to untether the global economy from
fossil fuels and we can transition in a
way that's just that provides security
for communities who are dependent on
these industries but we can only do that
if we start transitioning now and offer
an opportunity that delivers new green
jobs for these communities and what
about you bob do you think that that
pace of transition needs to be quicker
certainly needs to be quicker but the
international energy agency earlier this
year was very clear if we want to get to
net zero emissions of greenhouse gases
by the middle of the century there
should be no
new development of coal oil and gas and
that's right across the world because
the reserves we already have are already
more than we can afford to burn if we
want to get to that 20 50 target so
every country including the uk
should not be exploring for more oil
coal and gas and it's unfortunate that
the current that the uk government has
still said that it wants exploration to
continue in the north sea yeah you're
quite right to bring up the iea there
and let's just look at that quote the
executive director of iea has said if
governments are serious about the
climate crisis there can be no new
investments in oil gas and coal from now
and that's a key distinction isn't it
fatima it's one thing using what you've
already got it's another thing pouring
money into into new fossil fuel
i mean absolutely and i think that's
where we see the hypocrisy of
governments who are telling us that we
need to take individual action that the
climate crisis is real and at the same
time we have the uk government who's
hosting a un climate conference one of
the most and the most important
international conference on climate and
is at the same time exploring new oil in
the north sea opening new coal mines and
cumbria um that just doesn't make sense
to anybody and i think that's
that's something i think we're all
concerned about and is creating a lot of
anxiety for people because we just see
that the words and their action is not
matching
all right well you mentioned the uk
government there of course hosting cop
26 there as you were saying at fatima
it's worth pointing out the government's
stance a government spokesman has said
we will continue to need oil and gas in
the coming years as it is still vital to
the production of many everyday
essentials bob what do you think do you
think that's damaging to our credibility
as host of cop 26 when we say that
oil and gas is and coal is still vital
to our everyday needs
well it's clear that we're not going to
stop using fossil fuels overnight so it
will be a reduction over time but the
problem that the government has is that
it's basically saying do as we say not
as we do if it wants other countries to
commit to net zero by 2050 which it's
quite rightly doing ahead of cop26 and
it needs to lead by example by allowing
exploration to continue it risks
um
contributing to an oversupply of fossil
fuels which will depress the price and
make it more difficult to replace fossil
fuels it also means a lot of people are
going to lose money because my bet is we
are going to get to net zero by 2050 and
a lot of people who are betting on us
missing that target are going to lose
money by investing in fossil fuels it's
a bad bet to make yeah you snooze you
lose i suppose and fatima what do you
think do you think the uk can be
successful in persuading other countries
to stick to commitments when we're still
considering investments of our own
just briefly i mean no i don't i no i
don't think so and it's not just new
investments and new exploration the
government is propping up the fossil
fuel industry we subsidize the fossil
fuel industry 10.5 billion every year
the highest rate of subsidies in all of
europe so i don't know how this
government can call itself a leader when
it's it's backing up the fossil fuel
industry and really getting in the way
from us transitioning into a green
economy